years original area of expertise it was
in multi-core computing and so even
drawn is the problem there this
collaboration get chef look minute
working thank you can you hear me yep so
I'd like to start with a poem a poem
that I really like by a German poet
called Reiner Maria Rilke so let me read
it to you in mail or you can read it
with me so it's called the man watching
I can tell by the way the trees beat
after so many dull days on my worried
windowpanes that a storm is coming
and I hear the far-off fields say things
I can't bear without a friend I can't
love without a sister the storm the
shape-shifter of shapes drives on across
the woods and across time and the world
looks as if it had no age the landscape
like a line in the Salem book is
seriousness and weight and eternity what
we choose to fight is so tiny
what fights with us is so great if only
we could let ourselves be dominated as
things do by some immense storm we would
become strong too and not need names
when we win it's with small things and
the triumph itself makes us small what
is extraordinary and eternal does not
want to be bent by us I mean the angel
who appeared to the wrestlers in the Old
Testament when the rest of the sinners
grew long like metal strings felt them
under his fingers like cords of deep
music whoever was beaten by this angel
who often simply declined to fight went
away proud and strengthened and great
from that harsh hand that needed him as
if to change his shape winning does not
tempt that man this is how he grows by
being defeated decisively by constantly
greater beings
so this poem to me describes scientists
and more than scientists neurobiologists
and more than ever biologist Jeff and
all this thing about humbling is what
happened to me when I joined Jeff in his
quest
so I'm gonna tell you a little bit about
it
and so I'm going to talk about
high-throughput connectomics or
essentially how to make you know this
dream of actually getting large you know
neural circuits that we can take a look
at so one tenth of a second that's what
it takes you to actually know that this
is Mount Fuji okay in that time okay
about 20 neurons fire in sequence
okay if 20 things are firing in sequence
that's the depth of this circuit right
then it really must have ridiculous
levels of parallelism and this is where
I came to all this quest from I you know
I did 30 years almost of kind of
designing multi-core algorithms and I
kind of painted a conclusion which I
think many people have reached that by
connecting von Neumann machines together
we're not going to actually design
something that has massive parallelism
it's just not going to happen and so I
went around and started talking to
people about you know about how this
computation unfolds in brain I read Les
valiance you know book and I was all
geared up but very quickly I realized
that you know the truth is that the
neurobiologist don't have that many
circuits okay and so this was my quest
essentially this is what I decided that
I wanted to do I wanted to actually find
such circuits and maybe figure out you
know what they look like and then be
able to do some you know some theory
because in the end that's what I wanted
to do I wanted like many of you to do
theory of you know parallelism in the
brain
so with that quest ok I actually had a
you know a long conversation with
Sebastian sung who told me this was not
a field for amateurs you're not going to
come over and tell the neurobiologist
you want some you know stuff and then
they're gonna give it to you you've got
to actually earn you know them talking
to you maybe times have changed I don't
know you know but uh but anyway so and
then then luck happened so this is my
dog Aussie and he happened to fall in
love with Geoff's dog in the park
ok and while these dogs were romancing
one another
Jeff and I got to talking it was a
one-way romance my dog has really got a
thing for a mini ok ok like I come clean
buddy what do we need to do alright and
so I started talking to Jeff and you
know he allowed me to join in on his
project on his quest and so the goal of
course is to get a brain graph a
connectome ok
and you know if you look at connectomes
i want to give you a feel of the the
orders of magnitude here so and by the
way i'm gonna repeat a little bit of
Jeff's talk for the sake of people that
weren't here before so bear with me
so ok so you know a fly you know is
about a thousand or a hundred thousand
neurons a hundred synapses per node so
maybe 10 million edges ok in this graph
Mouse cortex about 4 million neurons
10,000 synapses per node we think
something like that so 40 billion edges
ok these are starting to be big graph so
human cortex is 30 billion neurons
10,000 synapses
so 300 trillion edges you know a whole
brain is a quadrillion edges okay policy
is somewhere here in the five trillion
edges by an edge an edge I mean a
synapse
I'm counting a synapse an edge I'm kind
of bending things a little bit but yeah
so in the graph if I just take a
connectivity graph every every nerve you
know soma is a is a node and all the
synapses are edges from it then that's
what I'm that's what I'm counting and
and meaning is over here Jeff thinks
mini is human and so that's where we are
okay so when I came to this area here is
the kind of the plan of how people set
about to do this kind of you know
looking for a connectome so you start
out with the brain like you like Jeff
told you in a resin and you do this kind
of you know cutting which we'll talk in
a second then you image things with a
microscope then you do alignment and
then you do reconstruction okay of this
data and then the truth is we don't
really know what to do after that okay
so there's a lot of things that we might
do but we don't really know and this is
where you know I'd like to have a
discussion about what we might do okay
so Jeff design this microtome okay it
slices this these slivers of brain onto
a tape right which then you know this
brain on tape then gets imaged in an
electron microscope and here is an
example example of ten thousand sections
about a hundred terabytes of data right
which look like this kind of a cube and
if you actually want to see what the
size of this thing this is what it is
right it's very small grain of salt okay
and so a grain of salt is about a
hundred terabytes that's telling you
what kind of data we have to process
what kind of processing we have to do
and the problem until very a few years
ago was that even getting this data was
enormous ly painful it took several
years to get this little grain of salt
okay so you know suddenly the problem
grew and this is through you know Jeff's
efforts and zeiss's efforts they've
actually designed this microscope that
now generates half a terabyte per hour
so now okay
if we actually want to process this data
what we're talking about okay is
processing data that comes off a
microscope at about half a terabyte an
hour and the bottleneck is this
reconstruction of you know the
connectome from the e/m images so we're
talking about really big data okay so
you know this these little the dendritic
arbors that you saw before are about 10
terabytes you know and we often handle
things that are a few terabytes right
now a cubic millimeter okay is about the
size of the Walmart database two
petabytes a rodent brain is about an
exabyte that's like you know a tenth of
Google and you know a whole brain if I
took the imagery as a zettabyte that's
about all the that's all the storage on
all the computers in the world right now
maybe I maybe it's to zettabyte now the
whole everything in the world
so our target is this cubic millimeter
okay
now with that in mind okay
people have tried to come up with ways
of doing this my colleague Sebastian
Seung his idea is to crowdsource this so
he has this beautiful program called I
wire you can go online and play with I
wire and there you know people can
actually sit and help in the process by
actually tracing you know neurons in
electron microscopy stacks okay so do
the kind of stuff that Jeff talked about
in his talk okay but now we're
crowdsourcing this and you know you
could do a cubic millimeter like this
okay about twelve thousand man years I
think this is a very easy you know
generous estimate and the whole mouse
would take a long time so we might be
able to do this but this is not an
approach really that is going to scale
okay and the you know it's not clear
even today to what extent you know if we
crowdsource things and people do this we
will actually get data of good enough
quality that we can trust it okay
it may be so but but this will introduce
a whole lot of other problems we might
have to have several people do the same
thing and then decide on how we're going
to kind of combine I don't think that
this approach even though it will be
great for generating some small sets
will will be the thing that will save us
so so then if that's not what we're
going to do then what we need to do is
actually find automated ways of doing it
okay so cubic millimeter to petabytes I
can pass that you know you know on to
the cloud using a dedicated fiber okay
maybe or I can ship disks you know I can
ship discs to AWS that might be another
solution for doing this so at half a
terabyte an hour we would just put these
things on disks and ship them and get
them back and so on so forth this might
be another approach ten cubic
millimeters maybe you know if you want
to do a whole Mouse I don't think we're
gonna keep a mouse on the Amazon Cloud
okay so I don't think that's happening
and what this tells me right is that you
know we really need to reconstruct the
connectome you know at the pace of the
microscope and near the microscope okay
so this was the goal that we set
ourselves we wanted to design a system
that would allow us and a set of Albin's
that would allow us to actually do this
kind of you know reconstruction at the
pace of the microscope near the
microscope which is I guess an area that
I would call connectomics on-demand so I
want to start by telling you how a
traditional connectomics on-demand
pipeline works so here is the the idea
so you get an en stack and you have to
essentially first align the stack okay
this is what people do first they align
this data set and then you run on this
image stack you run a machine learning
algorithm that actually detects what are
the membranes in this image okay and
then you use a classical algorithm that
people use in in graphics and other
biological applications which is called
watershed right we basically try to use
the membranes as guidelines for kind of
spreading out and deciding which pixels
belong inside the membrane and which are
outside it and you do that okay from a
set of seeds that are essentially an
over seeding of the original set so I
take you know I take this these
membranes and I might in each one of
these neurons
little neuron sections throw many seeds
and I run the watershed together to try
to kind of flood feel kind of these
these neurons and what you get is
something that is you know there are a
lot more objects than what we probably
need and probably have and so you
agglomerate them I'm going to show you
this in a second in in the on the images
so I agglomerate things and I do this in
separate blocks we have glom right
things and then we merge the blocks okay
after we merge the blocks so we've got
now these merged blocks of hopefully
good looking neurons then we run a
synapse detection algorithm an algorithm
that in these images detects where the
synapses are and finally after doing all
that we skeletonize the you know we
skeletonize the neurons that we have and
we can generate a graph we have the
connectivity we have the you know the
skeletons and from this we can actually
generate a graph okay and this graph is
the graph that we are supposedly going
to as computer scientists look at and
try to have some understandings of
what's going on here now the parts that
involve machine learning okay actually
require orders of magnitude more compute
than all the other parts okay and
they've been the bottleneck for this
kind of effort so let me explain a
little bit more about the you know the
details of this so so here's an align
data set okay and this is the raw stuff
that you get okay and you can see that
it's aligned because things are kind of
flowing right and they look like they're
smooth and flowing through this is
actually telling you that this is
actually in in good shape and
and so we take this aligned data okay
and this is the raw input to our to the
kind of traditional pipeline system now
take that okay and now what we want to
do now is figure out where the membranes
are okay and so our approach there are
many approaches to to actually detecting
the membranes and we were for a very
long time
toying around with these various
approaches okay I at this point and I
actually believe this is an art and not
a science okay really so many people
believe that you need very powerful deep
neural networks to do very accurate
detection of membranes okay and our
approach was actually to take a very you
know kind of shallow Network and
actually the the ability to you know the
the fact that the network wasn't that
accurate we actually thought that so
this is gonna help us in fact it does it
did help us okay because if you think
about it if you're very accurate you get
the membranes really accurately your
chances of kind of missing and you know
things and not fitting well with the
next layer are higher so we kind of used
a very shallow Network okay and we built
an execution framework for running these
networks
okay this execution framework is called
xnn we actually use CPU to do this okay
so in fact our whole pipeline runs on
the 72 node CPU okay not a not a farm of
GPUs okay
and so we used a lot of you know this
multi-core is is kind of my kind of
stuff so we built this pipeline the
pipeline rat runs on the data generates
the machine learning you know algorithms
runs them on the data and what you get
is something like this this is a view
into our pipeline so you start out with
the raw data
okay the electron microscopy and now you
start you run the algorithm to get the
probability map so
is an example of the of the
probabilities and you can see there are
areas where we're not trying to get them
where there are errors so we're just
blocking these out for now we kind of
deal with them later then okay the next
step is to actually do a watershed and
you can see that it there's really kind
of an over segmentation if there was a
seed here in a seat I'm sorry if there
was a let's see a seed here and here
then it might be kind of split around
and then the next step is to kind of
agglomerate things the little things are
all agglomerating together okay and then
the blocks themselves are all
agglomerating together okay so now we
have essentially you know created this
kind of these objects inside this slice
and we do this in this is a
two-dimensional view but we're doing
this in 3d okay and so if you want to
think about the traditional approach it
would be first expand the objects then
agglomerate them the idea is i
flood-fill i create these kind of
contours of the of the various pieces of
the neurons and then I try to figure out
with machine learning algorithms how
they fit together and that's the
approach okay so you see you run the
watershed the watershed an algorithm is
actually the watershed gives me these
chunks right and then I use the kind of
a you know actually a random forest
algorithm to kind of decide which chunks
should be together and I agglomerate
things together and that is my neuron
okay
and this is an example of the pipeline
that my postdocs your mijovich and Alex
and that they have put together it's an
example of an execution of this pipeline
this is on a data set that Bobby Kasturi
did in Jeff's lab and so you can see
things are you know there's a lot of
things that are that look good but
overall this law doesn't look that good
it shouldn't be that pink first of all
right I mean it couldn't be that it
can't be that everything here is you
know because there's so much of this
pink color so it's good but it's but
it's not great
okay so but I will say it's very fast
this is at the speed of the microscope
okay we're very close to the speed of
the microscope so on our 72 core machine
this is about four hours four terabytes
so it's 2x lower than than the
microscope and essentially what we
managed to do you know just in terms of
computer sciences what we did was we
took these algorithms and we found an
algorithm in an execution environment
that reduced the time that was spent on
the convolutional neural network part to
be a reasonable chunk of the compute and
now it runs at a reasonable time okay
then you need to do synapse detection
okay this is one of many algorithms
people have come up with many beautiful
algorithms this one is by you know this
approaches by my student Shivani so
again the idea is I take an electron
microscopy images I take the membranes I
take what the segmentation is and I try
to detect two things vesicles
and cleft so here for example is an
example of a synapse right this would be
the axon right and this would be the
dendrite you can tell that this is the
axon right because there are these
little vesicles that contain
neurotransmitter that Jeff talked about
so what we do is we detect separately
the vesicles and detect separately you
know the kind of this kind of density
between the the axon and the dendrite
and if we find a place where we have
both of them then we declare this to be
a synapse okay and here are some
examples of synapses found by this
algorithm so we have this synapse
detection tool right here's an example
of one thing we used it for this is a
kind of an interesting example we
automatically find right that there is
an axon here that is touching you know
that is this is the axon in blue right
and it's creating the synapse in two
places with this dendritic Arbor which
Jeff says is inhibitory yes okay this is
actually a really interesting thing this
is one of those first things that I that
I kind of learned from this work that I
didn't know before so when I was reading
you know when I was reading valiance
papers one of the first things that he
was saying in his in his modeling of
things is that if you actually want to
believe in this random graph model and
that you can it's already defined and
now you want to define concepts by with
things that actually kind of
have you no connectivity enough
connectivity it turns out from from
lessons modeling that there have to be
super-powerful synapses
okay the synapses have got to be super
powerful and yet it didn't look like
that from the from the data that people
were talking about that synapses were
super powerful but what it actually
turns out from Jeff's work and things
like this is that we do have super
powerful synapses it's just that they're
created by having the same right axon in
you know can create synapses with the
same dendrite in multiple places that is
the strong synapse so they do exist
so this completely theoretical
calculation has led to a claim that we
actually substantiate him some in some
sense yes please I don't see you have
ten connections between two parental
cells why this is a super powerful
synapse given that release probabilities
make it point five or so right so I'm
I'm not going to claim okay that this is
the you know the complete proof of this
this actually you actually need to do
some measurements to actually and do
this many many times to actually
validate the thing but at least it's a
hint that it exists that these you know
that it actually if the thing if what it
looked like was that you know every you
know every axon innervated a dendrite in
one place you know and there are many
that innervated but but it then goes on
to the next one in the next one then we
would clearly know that what he was
claiming was wrong okay so this I I
would say this is a this is a claim that
at least it's not impossible okay that's
what I would say okay it's giving us a
way for this to be true
but I find it all so fascinating that we
found you know that we can fight we will
find these things automatically we'll
get these graphs and we'll get them
automatically which is really uh you
know fascinating to me okay so yes I'm
gonna talk about that quite a bit yeah
yeah the what I wanted you to kind of
understand is that what we're doing is I
have these you know I
in the traditional pipeline what I do is
imagine that I have these you know I've
actually kind of done this to some
extent across and I am now combining
things together okay and I will talk
about how to how we do this in a minute
yeah so what we do is we we train on one
region and then so first of all the
ground truth is generated by having a
bunch of neurobiologists go over and
create a ground truth right and then we
also create some other kind of tests
regions on which we are going to check
the validity or validation sets right
and we have a neurobiologist segment
both of them okay and so now we have
these ground truths in several places
we train only on one and test on the
other that's our approach okay you can
argue that there are problems with this
but but I'm just saying this is what
most people do right now okay
yes
so agreed and so I think that you know
there's a lot more machine learning work
to be done here right to make this
extend to very large volumes and I'm
going to show you a little bit of how I
think we should approach it but I'm not
going to claim that this is I your what
you're raising is a great issue okay and
I'm gonna show you how we think we can
approach it okay good so we've got all
this stuff you know but these pipelines
have you know a lot of problems we're
we're seeing that the quality of the
segmentation that we get by doing this
kind of watershed in the glom raishin is
just not as good as what people can do
okay
so I want to describe to you a different
approach okay this is a an approach that
that tries to kind of mimic what a
neurobiologist would do when accessing
this data okay so the idea would be
first I skeletonize the data sets so
what that means is I go through and
every time that I see something that I
think is a neuron I put a dot in it in
the dot and the dot not so I I'm getting
this kind of skeleton okay of things
something like this okay so what this is
actually you know this is actually data
from Ravi Simone's lab at Harvard okay
so so the so the the first part is I
skeletonize okay and then I expand okay
that's gonna be our approach now you
know this this might not be you know if
you're doing it for all you're looking
for is the graph then maybe you don't
even need the second part okay but we
are actually going to use this second
part to actually make the skeletons be
better even if I'm only going to
generate a graph from them in the end
okay okay so
so a neurobiologist you know skeletonize
is the objects perfectly okay picking
one seed per object per slice and then
the automatic approach okay to date was
really you know to get a skeleton you
would just take a dense segmentation
like i showed you and you would kind of
skeletonize that okay so our new
approach okay is to actually try to
learn to pick one seed per object so do
the same thing that a neurobiologist
would do that's what we're gonna try to
do okay
okay so here is a first attempt at this
this is uh where is your own right there
my brilliant postdoc your own really
honestly you came up with this beautiful
idea okay of how did how to kind of
really mimic very cheaply what people do
so what you do is this okay you take the
suppose you're in segment it up to a
certain point you take the prior mass
that you have you take the electron
microscopy you take your membrane
predictions and you use all these to
kind of predict where the neuron would
go to in the next slice okay so we use
this is running on you know on the same
xnn framework that I told you about with
a convolutional neural network okay so
the idea then is I'm just going to be
doing classification right what I'm
gonna do is for each pixel you know in
the previous mask I'm gonna ask where
you what you know for each sorry pixel
in the new image I'm gonna ask does it
belong or does it not belong to this one
class in the other image okay in the
prior image okay and this same approach
actually people that uh at at Google
have come up with a similar kind of
approach okay I'll talk about that in a
second okay so here's an example of your
owns algorithm running mask extend
running on a dataset so what you can see
as it's managing to track a really tiny
you know neuro right through the volume
the red right are the are the membrane
probabilities right and this and the end
of and the kind of the green frame that
you're seeing is is the window that the
CNN is being applied to and there it is
it's continuously tracking it okay which
was what what a neurobiologist would do
if he was going through this volume
so actually it looks like there's a
section where it's split off the - um
yeah could so what happens is yeah so
part of the thing that this can do right
you could do at least is follow one and
then follow the other you could do that
okay I'll talk about this all these
these issues in a second give me a sec
here I just want to show you here you
can see you know again
this is the UH the tracking this is the
neuron this is where it is on the horse
this is in the whole volume this is
where we are okay here is what it looks
like you know it gets thin and fat and
thin and fat okay
and it's continuously tracking this
okay and as as as we say here it could
expand it could shrink all these things
together all these things could happen
but our hope is right that with using
this kind of an approach as opposed to
an approach where I try to take the
little pieces and all agglomerate them
together what I have here is a lot more
context right and maybe this is the key
thing that I want to say is that what
we've learned from all this I think Jeff
you'll agree with me is that you need a
lot more context to understand what's
going on okay and that any kind of
automated approach should try to get
more context because that is what you
know people use in order to do this you
know in Jeff's lab Daniel Berger who is
the world's top connectomics
segmentation guy right
what he does is sometimes he actually
manages to track things that don't look
like they could ever be the same thing
because he has contexts he's seen a lot
of these and he knows how to look at the
bigger picture and then figure out
what's going on and this is what was
missing from the prior pipelines okay I
think you've seen enough in this so you
also have to kind of do a little bit of
expansion and a little bit of erosion so
that you actually keep you know your
keep working on something that is for
the machine learning algorithm works
exactly the same okay okay so and here
is how good masks extend is okay so what
you're seeing here this is mask extend
this is the originally and this is where
we're looking at this is a this is the
human okay and this is a traditional
pipeline okay so this is an
agglomeration based pipeline okay this
is mask extend I want you to just look
at this you know this new right here
okay this axon right there okay so what
you're gonna see is that the human
doesn't change color masks extend
doesn't change color but here we go that
was a split arrow right there right did
you see this the neuron was actually
split and you'll see this thing happen
again here this thing is going to again
change colors because the
that does the agglomeration okay just
messes up hey let's watch it one more
time there we go another color okay so
every time that that happens in the
duration algum you've lost it right and
what you see is that when you go and
track these things and they are
ridiculously long okay and what happens
is you lose it and it breaks in many
places okay and and there we are that
that's not what we need we really need
that connectivity and and these new arts
they go in crazy ways you know one
through by the other and so on so we've
got to really figure out how to do this
tracking without error okay okay so
here's here are a few examples of you
know running masks extend starting at
the lowest level we just take seeds here
and we just extend them through and you
can see that they go through the volume
very beautifully you know so the
question then is okay so can we take
this approach and use it right for the
whole you know volume right so we're
gonna do the whole volume by doing
repeated mask extends okay and what you
see here right is an example of just you
know three thousand processes it looks
really like a lot okay but oh and I want
so I wanted to say one more thing this
this idea right of of using repeated
kind of applications like this is the
approach that people have taken Google
they have an algorithm which is called
what does it call your own their album
select the fun-filled networks okay
which is this exact kind of approach and
they repeatedly apply it to the neurons
okay you know what you see here is about
point eight percent of the volume it
looks like a lot okay but you have to
understand
this is really slow okay and so you
could I'm sorry you could do this you
could take this approach okay if maybe
if you are Google and you have a lot of
CPUs available a lot of GPU is available
okay but we were looking for a more
efficient way of doing this okay and
there are also issues with this approach
of repeatedly applying this mask extent
okay
so first of all you know when you start
at the bottom level you just seed all
the neurons but as you're going through
the volume okay so what about you know
in the next layers of the next layers
where do you place the seeds where do
you start the objects you know how do
you resolve conflicts between extensions
right I've extended you want an
extension another one is it the same
neuron or different neurons I have to
take these kinds of decisions and I'm
taking them remember if I do this
approach I'm taking them in an
independent way I do one and then I do
the other so they're not happening at
the same time you know I have to merge
proposals and it's not clear this is
gonna be a kind of heuristic you know
and it's not clear that these kinds of
heuristics are gonna get you anywhere
and in the end also your recomputing on
the same areas because when you do one
you're looking at a window and then on
the next one and the next one and you're
basically going over the same data set
so it's kind of really slow what we'd
really like to do is the same thing that
we do in the other pipeline which is go
you know fully convolutional e on the
whole volume
actually do you also only signal one
direction or do you sue both directions
say it again you only sleep in one
direction through the quali or do suit
both directions well in what I was
proposing you just do it in one
direction but but right just one
direction yeah so faced with this Johan
came up with another idea another
algorithmic approach okay and here is
the the idea okay
we're gonna actually have an algorithm
that's called multi mask okay it is
going to try to mimic the algorithm that
has many you know that does these these
kind of extensions but instead of doing
them one at a time we're gonna do them
all together at the same time okay so
imagine that what I do is if I have the
en for the input in the end for one guy
in the a.m. for the next one right what
we're going to do is we're going to take
the seeds in the en for one layer okay
and we're going to predict a
segmentation into the other layer as if
we didn't ask extend on each and every
one of these neurons but we're going to
do it all together at the same time
so the same network is actually going to
look at all of these separate neurons
together okay
and so here's the problem that you face
when you want to do this you know mask
extent works because it's really just
kind of extending the classification of
one object and asking you know is this
does this belong to it or not okay it
does a classification okay and and you
know classifying is what neural networks
do really well okay but what we really
want to do here is closer to clustering
what we really want to do is we don't
know how many of these we have and we
want to just take the pixels and cluster
them together right into these neurons
and so how do you translate you know how
do you transform an algorithm that was a
classification algorithm into a
clustering algorithm okay if you think
about it from the neural networks kind
of perspective and I'm gonna assume
people know a little bit about neural
networks here right the idea is this
right that mask extent was successful
because the convolutional neural network
is very good at just you have two
classes and you just say you know which
one is it in or out of the object okay
and for any K in fact this is it's
really good at this right if I know what
the classes are ahead of time I run the
network and I can do this classification
okay now when I don't know you know when
I don't know how many classes I have how
do I do this okay
and so your ron's approach was to do the
following kind of trick okay what we're
going to do is we want to do
classification we don't know how many
neurons neurons we have and we don't
know what they are and when we're
training we definitely don't know what
the data set is going to look like I
can't pick how many outputs I'm gonna
have in my convolutional neural network
right when I am doing the training ok
cuz every image is going to look
differently and so what we do is this so
we're gonna take a sequence of
convolutional neural networks okay and
each of them is going to have a fixed K
number of outputs okay and we are going
to map all the objects that we have into
a set of different applications of the
convolutional neural network in
take the cross product of that and that
is going to be the output that is going
to actually determine you know kind of
do an extension of the object into the
next layer okay I'm going to show you
what I mean by that in a second but what
I want you to understand is that because
each of them can only do you know some
kind of fixed class I'm going to use you
know the kind of combination of all of
them to do the full thing okay so this
is our 3c cross classification
clustering algorithm okay and here it
here is how it works okay so imagine
that this is your this is your original
kind of label space these are your the
neurons right and these let's say these
are their real names okay just I'm just
identifying them so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna rename them I'm gonna rename
these neurons and I'm gonna read that
name then let's say using four colors
okay so four colors and imagine that
what this is then is a is a base you
know it's a three-digit number base four
okay so for example this neuron I'm
gonna call it the green green what is it
purple neuron okay and this one is gonna
be blue blue blue and this one is going
to be green purple orange right so I
renamed them okay and now what I want to
do okay what I'm gonna do now is okay
I'm gonna actually take and you know I'm
gonna break down write the
classification into a set of
classifications one for each one of the
levels of this kind of name that I've
given it so in the first classification
you know the guys that have this guy has
a is green okay and this guy is green so
they both are exactly in the same class
okay in the next classification they're
not right in the next classification
here they're not similarly here this guy
in all of them is blue and so on okay
and I'm going to run these
classifications separately now okay each
one of them
so it very well you know it seems weird
that I'm saying this and this are the
same class right and and and so when I
extend this and I extend that I'm gonna
extend them like they're one object okay
but that's okay because when I go to the
next classification here on actually
going to treat them as separate ones and
so on so you take the input you take
your prior segmentation you break it
down okay in this case into five
different so this is a base kind of five
I have sorry not base five but five
different segmentations so it's a five
digit kind of application and you can
see that this purple guy is blue green
purple orange green that's its name okay
I do the I run the convolutional neural
network to do the classification a kind
of you know to say for each pixel in the
target what does it or belong or doesn't
belong to this object and I get these
maps and then what I do is I take all
these maps right and I kind of give the
guy you know I do our max on all these
and then I get you know for each one of
them I kind of decide right what the
name of this guy is by taking his name
in all of them together okay and that
gives you the output
so essentially what I've done right is
I've taken an I'm kind of doing this
multiple masks it extends all at the
same time okay I'm mimicking you know
within a in a computer science II kind
of way the behavior of you know many
parallel neurobiologists working on the
data set okay
so this is the kind of stuff that we can
do you know to kind of get this stuff to
be both accurate and and have context
yes is what randomly okay so how do you
continue across the image stack okay you
know the question is where do neurons
begin right you didn't have this problem
in mask extent okay and also we have to
regularize things so we do this a little
bit differently than what I suggested
what we do is this okay we take the
whole volume okay and we do an automated
seeding of the volume okay an over
seeding an over seeding meaning that in
each one of these neurons I might get
multiple seeds in it in my seeding so I
automatically seed things okay just by
essentially think of it as just doing a
similar algorithm to the you know to the
watershed algorithm I'm basically
picking you know places that I think are
you know belong in the same run and I
might have it might be that I have
multiple seeds like this in a given
neuron okay and then I use the algorithm
to predict a segmentation okay and I
threshold
okay the segmentation I use it to
actually do this kind of projection
between slices to determine which neuron
you know I believe is which one you know
for each pixel whether it belong to
which neuron in the original seating it
belongs to okay so here's what it looks
like so if I take the if this is the
priory m and this is the next en okay
what we do is you know we seed the whole
thing so here are the seeds in the prior
and here are the seeds in the next one
and this I do beforehand okay and then
what I do is okay I actually take and do
this kind of segmentation that we talked
about okay so I'm running the algorithm
okay and I get a segmentation here okay
and I do the same thing the other way
too okay from the next slice backwards
so take my seeds here map them into here
take those nap them into there okay and
now what I have is essentially these you
know I have a prediction for you know
from here to there and from there to
here okay and I'm now going to use this
okay to actually decide okay what's
right and what's wrong what's correct
and what is not okay and I do this by
actually I'm gonna match the IDS okay
and what this is gonna allow me to do is
as follows here is an example right I
have you know the seeds of the prior and
the seeds of the next and then I have
the segmentation of the prior this way
and the segmentation of the next this
way and if you look here there's a split
error here okay what does it mean that
there is a split error what it means is
this if you look at the if you know if
you look at at this at the next slice
right you can see that in here right
it's not broken like that it actually
seems like this whole thing is one
neuron okay whereas here there was some
reason for some reason in the e/m right
there was something that that the
algorithm thought was a membrane and
therefore this one is separate from that
one okay and in Prior algorithms this
would introduce an error okay because
now when I came to agglomerate this I
would get an error you know I get two
objects okay not necessarily
agglomerating them but what's gonna
happen now is essentially as follows is
because what I can do now is if I match
the IDs what I notice is this I you know
I'm using you know the fact that I know
that you know when I seed things okay
I can introduce splits but if something
is merged it's a true thing okay this is
like an assumption right that we're
making that I'm not kind of merging
things across boundaries my
trust my seeding that it might oversee
things but it's not going to actually
cross boundaries with the seeds okay and
so what this means is that when I see
that this is actually connected I can
use that to correct this okay and
similarly there and that's what I do
okay so I fix things and what you get
from this algorithm is this beautiful
segmentation across the z-axis okay and
so these are seeds from the algorithm
okay these are seeds generated by the
algorithm that is going through the
volume
now okay so I've got the seeds and I've
gotten and I'm not getting that many
errors there okay the next thing I do is
I do this expansion algorithm
okay so expansion is actually important
okay so this is a real question for us
as computer scientists and for the you
know for the for the for the
neurobiologists right you know it's a
real question of whether or not we
really can trust just looking at graphs
and connectivity or do we actually need
to understand how things sit you know
volumetrically inside you know these
animals right and so the approach that
we're taking to do this expansion is
good whether what I have is a seeding
that comes from you know a
neurobiologist or a seeding that comes
from our automated technique okay so
imagine that I I did this in one of the
two ways either a neurobiologist gave me
the skeleton or my automated technique
gave me the skeleton I would do this
okay and then the next step that we want
to do is kind of expand the skeletons
okay so here's an example you know of a
skeletonization' of you know a c elegans
so neurobiologist has gone through and
kind of seeded this okay and now what we
want to do is so this is if I'm not
mistaken Jeff right all the data sets
for for worms are skeletons of this type
okay so when people say they have you
know the the connectome of of C elegans
they mean they have these skeletons that
a neurobiologist is placed okay okay so
but we want to turn this into actually
images of all the neurons volumetrically
okay and so what we do then is we have
you know there are many approaches to
doing this the one that we do is
essentially by kind of taking an
approach of you know looking at the
affinity graph and trying to kind of
decide for every pixel you know what
what is essentially the what are the
pixels that are of the closest affinity
to the one that I believe is already
inside my object which ones belong
together okay so the way you know that
that we do this is essentially we kind
of try to estimate whether there is you
know whether you know a path between two
pixels is actually going through a
membrane or not okay and you know your
hone and my student Rajeev just came
with a kind of a transformation that
turns this into a kind of a shortest
paths problem on the graph of the you
know of the probabilities of the you
know of something being a membrane or
not and so you run this algorithm and
what you get is this kind of expansion
you know that is very close to what the
human would do okay it needs some
correction but it actually delivers this
beautiful kind of expansion of you know
the objects so you have emcs right and
you have a probability map and you know
you're mimicking some you're doing
something that is very close to how a
human would fill this thing in okay
and then you can I mean you know this is
an example of urines work on expanding a
worm skeleton this is these are slices
through C elegans
okay
okay
yeah is the whole thing
so good so we do this expansion okay and
here's an example of after I die I've
done automatic skeletonization and I've
done expansion this is what my output
looks like okay so this is significantly
improved relative to what we had before
okay but you know so the good news is
that we have very few errors but the bad
news is that the errors are harder okay
so if you want to believe Rilke you know
we've made some progress maybe okay but
you know we still need to solve those
errors okay
what are these errors that happen one
thing that happens is that we still have
split errors okay so if you look for
example here can you see this right that
essentially this is the same neuron but
I have two seeds and after the whole
process I still have two seeds okay a
lot of this happens because I'm hitting
this you know I'm actually you know my
algorithm is very good along the z-axis
but is not that good along the XY axis
okay another thing that happens are
merge errors okay so for example you
know I'm kind of I kind of have one
object and it extends into the other
object okay so I still have those but
here's our idea okay we are going to try
to avoid as many of the split errors as
we can okay from from the point of view
of believing that merge errors okay can
actually be detected with more context
okay so this is kind of an approach that
says try to avoid the split errors they
are very kind of you know they're very
difficult to do but can be can be
avoided with local kind of stuff and
then we want to do and then we want to
do
a kind of fixing of the merge errors
okay and merge error detection requires
context and so what we do is as follows
basically what we're going to do is
we're going to use a neural network to
actually detect merge errors from
context you know have a lot more context
so the idea is right you know we are
going to try instead of looking at you
know a small piece of small slice of the
of the image you know or a bunch of
things and try to deduce from that local
information whether emerge happened or
not try to take a bigger context apply
machine learning algorithm and try to
see if you actually get you you can tell
if this is a merger or not okay and so
here's an example of this right here is
a merger these are two separate you know
new rights and they've been joined
together by the algorithm okay know what
happened here
that's not running anyway there was a
movie there so
I don't know why this of the movie is
not showing up
there right so here here they are and
you'll see that they have a you know
there's a shared membrane here
okay suddenly there is a membrane you
see but it doesn't detect it correctly
okay there was a membrane there didn't
detect it correctly and so I get a merge
error okay now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna try to understand from with
a bigger context that this happened okay
and just briefly I'll just say the way
we do this is okay we take this
algorithm the if you you could apply the
same algorithm to if you took a you know
letters okay that somebody wrote and
just connected them together okay so you
created merge errors here okay run it
through a kind of iron kind of neural
network and it will decide whether or
not this was a real merge or not and it
does it without understanding what the
letters are it's not like it's not like
the algorithm knows that this is a zero
and this is a five it's just trying to
learn the idea of something that is a
you know is you know morphologically the
same object or not and so what you get
what you see is if this is for example
these are the correct labels okay if we
run the algorithm with a prediction of
with 24 you can see okay this you know
that there is this kind of detection of
these mergers right if I use with 12
okay what you see is that I'm kind of
let's take the six for example it's if
it doesn't have enough context then it
actually thinks that these are two
separate objects there's a 0 and a 1
okay instead of a 6
yeah so you use a deep net it's
surprisingly this is just a deep network
it's just a deep network running on a
low resolution image of the whole thing
so I get a huge I'm looking at the whole
thing at low resolution right and I'm
doing that yeah no we're doing it for
everything it just it yes completely
it's just doing this independently of
the fact these are numbers that it
doesn't know that these are numbers yeah
yeah yeah no here's it's doing it for a
neuron look it's just detecting on this
thing it learns okay that you know this
for this for example is an area where
the potentially there is a merger okay
or or there and so on I think I have an
example here here look see so for
example it doesn't scream bloody murder
when it's a normal branch but here for
example it notices that this and that
this little it's learned that neurons
don't connect in this way okay
okay so to summarize I guess what I
wanna the story that I've been telling
you is the following story that you know
one approach would be to do kind of
expand you know do this kind of
expansion and then do merging of objects
that's one approach to building these
neurons the other approach is to do a
kind of you know skeletonization try to
build these skeletons by mimicking how
humans would do this and then expand the
skeletonization' okay and in the end
when we're done with all this okay the
goal that we have is actually to get
these kinds of graphs so our hope is
okay is to actually take this data
segment it and actually generate what we
call layout graphs okay this is at least
my my plan for this project because
we're gonna do a cubic millimeter okay
and you know even though Jeff wants to
keep a full segmentation of the thing
with all the details down the road I
don't think we'll be able to do that so
my hope is that down the road what
happens is actually that on the fly as
things go through the microscope come
out we get the data we run our algorithm
and we generate these layout graphs and
they kind of capture a lot of the
information that is in the you know in
the morphology of the neurons and you
know these all could all these edges and
everything could be labeled so that I
actually capture all the properties that
I actually might need the thickness and
you know other properties that I want of
the neuron but what I what what this
gives me is a way to represent petabytes
of data using gigabytes of graph and
that means that I can share it okay
people will actually be able to to mail
them to one another or at least have
them in a repository that you can
actually download it as opposed to these
petabytes of imagery even if we
segmented everything and kept it there
you wouldn't be able to see it okay and
from these graphs of course these graphs
have a lot more information that then
what
would need if all you wanted was you
know connectivity and so of course we
can from these graphs get a lot more you
know that we can translate this into
connectivity graphs and so on and I
really believe this I believe that we
are going to get there okay I believe
that we are going to get there the
techniques are improving all the time
we're slowly slowly you know getting to
a place where this is going to be
accurate enough so that we get
meaningful things
looks like those nodes are not
necessarily the nodes here these nodes
are these nodes are branches the
synapses are edges here each one of
these things is labeled say for example
with the thickness
I'm really trying this I and this I
embed in a 3d in a three-dimensional you
know representation so that I can
actually ask queries like you know is an
axon passing through a dendritic tree
and so on so forth yeah for showing this
morning right that's right that's right
I don't want to lose I don't want to
lose the morphology but I don't want to
keep all the pixels right this is really
what we're saying okay yes I think okay
so I think that this is a question that
has more to do where we are in our
research I think that when we start out
we probably have to have very good
accuracy just because we don't know
anything right and we don't want to make
mistakes but as we go along and we
understand more about what we actually
need it may very well be that we see
that there's you know little bit or
there are patterns a little variability
and I can actually you know live with
with errors okay so I think down the
road we will live with errors okay
[Music]
so I think we couldn't find it like they
are using Map Reduce
but there are something like that they
do not outside you couldn't find it
essentially clouds I think you should be
able to do I mean lots of these things
essentially very nicely I mean the
question that like if you sit with
apples I mean what do you want to do
essentially you see intersted he can't
do that
I mean maybe you should just use the
industry because if you want to so first
of all I'm a big fan of using anything
that one can use so I'm with you on that
I think that right now the idea of
shipping the data to Google and doing it
there is a beautiful idea
but if we want you know but if we want
this to approach to be applicable to
Naropa
labs across the world then III doubt
that the data is going to be shippable
is my problem my main problem is that I
don't think people are going to be
shipping the data so that that said I'm
looking at algorithms where people can
apply them locally now this might be a
mistake right but you know it's it's the
same kind of thing as the human genome
project when everybody started we're
talking about a lot of compute that very
few people could do and and then down
the road it's the kind of compute that
anybody can do so I think a combination
of the two right right now we do it with
massive computer and so on and later on
we do it with less computer matching so
there I mean if you are to just has
essentially one time through these
things and we couldn't do it several
patents that you need for example for
connectivity or like the clustering
needs to do more like essentially PFS
and that VFS is something that you can
just weave is a stream under the number
of wrongs or any combination that would
be a nice thing something can be I mean
I didn't have that before
I was making my laptop but who yet it
was differencing you have tons of this
computer and they are there I said you
can use them essentially and of course
the combination would be interesting
I don't know me the exact rate of
speaking to budget the exact combination
nice let's talk I mean I that glum glad
to talk absolutely yeah
yes oh I did this calculation actually I
don't remember let me think of a human
brain oh my god yeah
one second I'll tell you it would be in
the petabyte range if every synapse is a
byte then it's in the petabyte range yes
I take it the working hypothesis here is
that the layout graph is enough to
capture much of the interesting
behaviour the brain when the
connectivity graph is not is is this a
reasonable way to look at this um I
think that the answer is that we don't
know that's why that's why we're don't
we don't want to go here because we're
too afraid to lose what we might need so
for example just give you an example one
of the things that we're thinking about
right is morphology so if Jeff is right
and all these different types of neurons
need to be identified morphologically
and I need to do this automatically
because I'm not going to have a human do
this then I'd better know what the
morphology is if it's a pyramid
pyramidal neuron then I'd better be able
to identify it I'm not gonna identify it
from that okay so this data is going to
be important but I do agree that once
I've done a lot of analysis every person
will do a different thing on this and
get their own kind of graph and decide
what they want to do but since this is
small enough to be moveable and so on
and so forth
you know and I don't think we're gonna
do a human brain right I mean I said
petabytes but come on right most likely
we don't need that you know the truth
the truth be told I mean
Jeff you you did you you basically have
one you know one neuron fully mapped
inside thalamus right but we don't have
a pyramidal neuron right with all its
inputs right right we don't have right
exactly and not its axon so imagine that
I would get one like that with the you
know dendritic tree and the axon on the
other side and know what it looked like
that would already be a fantastic
achievement I think it would teach us so
much right so yes we I don't think we
need a whole brain and I don't think we
need we we just need some kind of a
presentation like this and then start
collecting the data right because it's
this is the thing yeah yeah cool yes did
you see something interesting when you
look to the graphs for example no I have
to listen so I wanna so I have to admit
that I've been doing this now for four
years this specific kind of thing of you
know for three years I think and slowly
slowly we're not getting there okay no
it's so painful I mean alone has been
doing you this all this time and the
techniques are getting better and we're
almost there but we're not there yet the
graph that you get even there when there
are it's too broken yet it's still too
broken but we're not that far away I'm
seriously I you know I'm gonna say you
know this is one of these things that
I've been humbled by I came in I thought
oh a couple of years thank you very much
Jeff you know here's your graphs and you
know a whole system you know you know
this whole people that MIT are very
arrogant so this is what I thought you
know and man was I wrong you know really
it's so so so hard to get it right okay
and so I think we will get there okay
we're gonna get there and you guys are
gonna get graphs okay but but you know
but it's going to take a few a couple of
more years to get to that
place okay and again once you know once
we get there okay then there's the next
question of what we do with the graphs
that we get okay and you know and like
Jeff said I really believe in this kind
of Galileo theory theory you know we're
just gonna look at it and well look okay
what's the look we're gonna look at it
and we're gonna see things okay this is
really the next big question what is the
look at it because the look at it is not
look at it using any other to you know
not with your eyes and not with any of
the algorithms that we have today okay
so for example right some people we
talked a little bit in the beginning of
the day about this idea that there is
some kind of canonical structure going
on here even kind of designing an
algorithm that will figure out what is
canonical and look through the data sift
through the data to find canonical
things this is a huge problem okay
people have started to do work on
actually using you know convolutional
neural networks to identify patterns and
graphs okay I think this for example is
work that could really take us forward
we need to do that kind of work people
want to do it because they want to do
you know they want to identify things in
the in the inner in you know in the
internet graph but forget that right
this is the real problem for which this
is applicable okay if we kind of
understand a little bit of what the
patterns look like for pyramidal neurons
connecting to one another and we can
identify these circuits in many place
bets already that's gonna be huge
okay so that is the next big thing here
is to actually try to build the tools to
look at this data set these data sets
yeah and I think with that I'm gonna
finish so let me just you know thank all
my you know the people in my group and
especially you know my postdoc see Aaron
and Alex who are really the people that
have you know made this thing this whole
project happen it's quite unbelievable
the amount of you know creativity and
hard work that goes into making
something like this happen anyway
yep
so I like the goal of getting a graph
but it seems like what you really want
is a graph with a probability right
because she seems I got a lot of these
classification right you don't want it
to be a chain this as strong as as
weakest like that's right that's right
you know let's say you're trying to test
some kind of computational model then
you might see sort of oh it's off by
just a couple of links and well maybe
those were errors right maybe I could
sort of go bad and grease another graph
that gets about as well right yeah does
that possibly you think of getting some
problem yeah we've talked about I think
you're absolutely right I think that
that we have to assign probabilities to
things right must yeah it's not gonna
work otherwise yeah absolutely yeah
I mean you could say something about the
possible role of modulation of the graph
structure and what I mean by that is
that the C elegance of these
neuromodulators can chemically change
the strength of actual synapses all just
actually change this result of
modulation
I I think we are amazed that you're
going that far in the into you know
there there's trouble even before that
would see elegance right I mean even
even just understanding the things that
we actually see statically or we even
know don't know how to do that right
correctly so you know I think that
people know a lot more about C elegans
than they did let's say five years ago
right and so I think there is hope I
don't think it's a done deal in any way
I think that you know there's a there's
a there's a group and that and at
Harvard I guess way alan lee if people
know him they they did some work right
with Davi bach and so on they they
actually what they did was they took you
know they took a mouse and did calcium
imaging of this mouse doing an activity
and then they sacrificed it and actually
got the connectome out by doing an
electron microscopy okay and so now you
have activity plus a graph okay and they
got some conclusions from this okay that
I think is the future for us okay to
actually get enough activity off a
collection of neurons so that we can
model the neurons the way they really
are okay
not I think there are beautiful models
for neurons today right but none of them
are based on an actual neuron right all
these models of how neurons act are
based on the fact that I you put some
electrical current into a you know into
parts of the the neuron I see the
reaction right but it's all artificial
okay so if we could actually get a
couple of neurons with high accuracy
then I think the connectome plus
understanding the real model of how
when a neuron looks like and from there
it's all simulation we will be able to
do it without actually having a brain so
I think the connectome will be our our
path to get you know to extend an
understanding from you know a very small
collection of neurons to large circuits
okay and then maybe we can understand
things that's my take on this right if
it's too detailed I'll just learning the
brain with the long term potentiation so
is whatever happens when when the hell
TP occurs visible at the levels that
you're looking at and would you be able
to annotate a graph with something like
the word strength so that the updated
strength of connections that we could
write so I think there's two parts that
the answer to this one is okay people
have started okay to actually try to
correlate write certain properties of
synapses is specifically the Bouton's
okay the kind of Jeff showed right there
you know correlate those the size the
you know the the number of theof
vesicles and so on so forth to the
strength of the synapse okay so there is
a there will be a morphological way to
kind of know maybe how strong a synapse
is just by looking at morphology without
actually having to check it chemically
or okay so I think that is I think that
is very much a doable thing okay but I
think that that probably you know that
probably will not be enough I think that
what I would like to see okay down the
road is for example a complete accurate
recording of you know of the
Trinity tree of a single pyramidal
neuron right and then I actually do
connectomics and get it out so I have
you know all the activities somehow with
some new form of calcium which people
don't have yet right some other kind of
detector and then see what the
morphology is like and from that I build
a model that I can then use given you
know given a certain morphology I will
know what what exactly this thing does
I think that's doable okay that kind of
thing if we have that I think does that
answer your question that this would be
something that we could use then to just
build you know understand what
everything is what it what is going on
even if the graph is random then I know
what would each component does
absolutely not I don't think no I don't
think it's I don't think it's enough I
think we're gonna if we understand a few
individual components and how they
interact and then we do simulation for
the rest I think that'll be good enough
and this is by the way very naive
because the brain also has a lot of
chemistry right they did you know
chemicals flood through things so I'm
really simplifying but what I mean is
that for the kind of thing that I'm
hoping to do I think this is what I want
I don't think that I I don't think that
I can make sense from thousands of you
know firings together not now not
without the connectome when you say what
do you mean because there's lot of
in this I think that everybody say them
that that is a hypothesis that exists
largely because there's no evidence one
way or the other I think it requires
that LTP that is the or something like
the efficacy of connections be what
changes as opposed to the wiring diagram
per se and the one thing that you have
to keep in mind is that you need
something that will store and and ground
in a human being for a hundred years no
one talks about LTP
I think believes that that kind of
mechanism lasts 100 years it's an
activity dependent change in efficacy
that is long term in the sense that it
works for hours maybe a day but what
definitely lasts four hundred years is a
wiring diagram because that's basically
many connections between nerve cells so
that even if one comes or goes you still
have a long term trace and the fact is
that all reflexes in the body like
tapping your patellar tendon and getting
your Trice figure of quadriceps to
twitch is not because of efficacy of
synapses it's actually because of wiring
diagram specificity of what is connected
to what it's a wiring diagram issue so I
wouldn't assume it's a random graph
until there's evidence it's a random
graph everything we've done where we've
traced suggests that axons are not
randomly intervening target cells but
they are selectively making lots of
synapses on some cells and not so many
on other cells in their same vicinity
and so I know it's a very attractive
idea but I I don't I wouldn't bet on it
at this point as a biologist those turn
out as a theorist as a biology
so I just want to quickly say this might
be a site for it
good interests interdisciplinary
discussion at some other point but uh
you know the recent history of say
algorithms in computer science the last
twenty years have been almost taken over
by madness and this is a huge superpower
that we can use for algorithms yeah and
saying that man this is a superpower
doesn't mean that every little decision
that our computer make sure the random
but just that man this injected in the
right amount of the right place greatly
simplifies things so you know something
in the wiring diagram where random the
analysis might be simpler it might be
simpler but but the fact is there's
nothing in biology that requires it to
be simpler everything biology argues
just the other way it's trying to make
it complicated enough to do whatever it
has to do there's no advantage in being
more simple analytically they're the
brain is not trying to be understood oh
sure sure sure folks with other members
have many benefits it also makes it more
robust for them the brain needs to be
robust it's not I would say that
redundancy might play a bigger role than
than randomness in in robustness you
know but maybe genetics and mutations
natural selection I think that random
process is super healthy for producing
of these phenomenal results I mean for
producing us so I think I think there is
some role of randomness I think there's
a lot of innate sort of wiring and
everything but I think randomness is
still useful I mean I think the argument
we see biologically is that early in
development at least in the parts of the
nervous system or we can analyze it
things are highly over connected but
it's not so much random well we could
say random in nonspecific lots of extra
connections yeah and out of this morass
of complexity comes the adult which is
highly unrounded and probably based on
experience but it's not the adult does
not random it's highly constrained you
know but it's good strained but I mean
even as you said before the left side
and the right side are gonna have
different connections from places right
there are levels where it doesn't matter
I guess and if it doesn't matter it's
gonna be random in some but random is a
tough way I'd love to talk about this
because for us I think as biologists
it's harder to make something completely
random given the fact that axons don't
go everywhere they go somewhere target
cells have neurotransmitter receptors
that only respond to particular
neurotransmitters it can't be purely
random no matter how you look at it it's
highly constrained by biology even if
you have a fully like determined
connected graph like is there an amount
of noise that you can inject into the
system and still gain some useful
information about like how those
circuits actually work like is there an
amount of randomness that's all there
for us
understand that that's an excellent
question that presumably one would get
the answer to if you had some actual
circuits see how how much you could
degrade them and still basically have
the same well we have some grand
refreshments
[Applause]